this is really a story of choices behind
me is the UK's defense spending as a
percentage of GDP since the end of the
Cold War less money being spent as the
perceived threat recedes much of that
money being spent elsewhere this is what
health spending has done over a similar
period not too far off but really moving
away over recent years and that's a
choice made by successive governments
but that reduction in spending has meant
a reduction in Armed Forces personnel
and you can see just how much that has
fallen but the UK isn't alone here many
other countries reacted the same way to
the end of the Cold War this shows the
proportion of GDP spent by different
countries over the same time it's a
similar picture this is where the UK is
in Gold we're in the middle of the pack
really you're behind us and Russia but
we spend much more than they we spend
more than they do in absolute tones then
you've got other countries like Poland
which today has announced it's
increasing its defense budget to four
percent of GDP the question is what do
we spend that that money on and this is
the equipment plan for the ministry of
Defense what they're going to spend
money on the next 10 years nuclear
deterrent is the biggest one then you've
got the Royal Air Force the Army is
getting less of that money which is why
we've heard some of these calls and this
comes back to the integrated review this
idea of a global Britain a tilt to the
indo-pacific and for that sort of
strategy you need new equipment best
exemplify by the Queen Elizabeth class
carriers two of them delivered at a huge
cost 6.4 billion pounds to project power
across the seas some experts have said
that's putting money in the wrong place
they're expensive setting ducks for
anti-ship missiles but land-based
systems often have similar problem
compare those air carriers to the Ajax
armored vehicle the mod signed a
contract for 5.5 billion pounds for 589
Vehicles supposed to come into service
in 2017 but they have been plagued by
technical problems around noise and
vibration and we are still waiting on
that and Ajax is just one Alberta giant
program the Public Accounts committee
has said the ministry of defense's
entire procurement program is broken so
there is a lot of money more than nearly
every other country on the planet and a
lot of it is not being spent well